we were woken this morning here by loud
explosions is it your view that the
russians are intent on taking this city
and removing president zielenski from
power
it's definitely our view that the
russians intend to invite the whole of
ukraine
uh the nonsense they were spouting about
the donbass and it were
you know as ever with a whole series of
dishonest claims are not the case and
that's why you've seen a number of
columns of russian army entering the
city from the south from the north from
belarus even
and indeed from the separatist region
but you know our assessment as of this
morning is that russia has not taken any
of its major objectives in fact it is
behind
it's hoped for timetable
they've lost over 450 personnel
and indeed as you've said on your report
one of the significant airports they
were trying to capture with their elite
spetsnaz
has failed to be taken and in fact the
ukrainians have taken it back
so i think contrary to great russian
claims and indeed president putin's sort
of vision that somehow the ukrainians
would be liberated and would be flocking
to his cause
he's got that completely wrong and the
russian army has failed to deliver on
day one its main objective
even so i mean the explosions this
morning are getting closer we're told
russian forces are making their way here
albeit with some resistance
if they do
topple this government do you accept
that the west has failed ukraine
well what i have said all along is that
ukraine needs its support and allies the
united kingdom sweden for example canada
and a number of other countries have
stood side by side of ukraine since 2014
we had operation orbital to help set up
and train we trained over 20 000
ukrainian soldiers
we were the first uh country to deploy
lethal aid to help the ukrainians in
europe alongside the united states and
now we're joined by four or five other
european countries i'm pleased to say
but you know the person who has failed
to live up to all his agreements
including the agreements that he has
signed as lately as 2010 or certainly
the russian federation has been
president putin he's failed to follow
international law he failed to respond
but the west democracy with respect
no with respect i mean the west has
failed to persuade president putin that
the price of invasion
is too high
i wrote an article in july january that
president putin was beyond this type of
persuasion you know president putin
i said and got criticized at the time
there was a whiff of munich about uh
president putin and it wasn't about the
bit about appeasement i was referring to
i was referring that in the munich in
1938 adolf hitler all along had a plan
to invade parts of europe and all the
diplomacy was about a straw man
sort of attempt by him to buy time putin
has been set on this for many many
months and certainly over a year
and i think that's why
you know it doesn't matter how much
effort we made and we all made
unbelievable answer effort we saw
president macron go with my prime
minister regularly spoke to putin didn't
matter
as we're seeing today it's not about the
donbass it's not about a minority it is
about agreed to subsume ukraine into the
russian federation or indeed uh for
president putin to land grab in a way
right but if you saw it coming
a year ago months ago
shouldn't the west and nato have been
more uh prepared for this let me just
read you what president zielenski who is
in this city we think somewhere probably
in his
bunker somewhere let me read you what he
said this morning he said we are
defending our state alone
like yesterday the world's most powerful
forces are watching from afar
as a military man how does that make you
feel
well
what it makes me feel is is the same
thing that you know many many people in
the west felt which was what you are
seeing on your cameras today is
illogical president putin didn't need to
do this he didn't need to uh occupy
which he's doing right now a sovereign
country he didn't none of it stacked up
none of the reasons why he would do it
would stack up a few of us felt that
and you know again i made a few comments
the other day about president putin
you know he's not doing something that's
logical he's doing something that is
about his ego and his legacy so you know
the west will act in accordance sorry
i'm talking about the west though mr
wallace i'm talking about the west's
response doing regardless of any nato
articles or rules is there not a moral
responsibility
on the west to protect a democratic
state from a
paranoid autocratic dictator
isn't that just basic humanity and
isn't that a moral mission
well it absolutely is a moral remission
which is why we have taken the step of
some of the toughest sanctions to be
placed on russia and going in now he's
still that's not working
he's not working the shells are coming
in look the missiles
so there are two other options mark
which is if you think president putin is
absolutely uh you know irrational tyrant
etc and all those things that you have
just said
uh which many of us do think he is in a
position that is beyond logic beyond
respect to other sovereign countries
there are a number of ways to stop him
or make it cost him one is sanctions one
is to help the ukrainians defend
themselves which is lethal aid which we
did alongside the united states quite
early on and training
we announced over a year ago that we
would be selling ships to ukraine uh
with missiles that would allow them to
defend their ports you know we have done
a lot the third option which is the
option that i've been quite open about
just to interrupt on that one just to
interrupt how are you going to get any
more military aid into this country if
it is controlled by the russians they
will control the airspace they will
control the borders and they will
control the sea borders how do you get
any more military help to help this it's
not going to happen is it
well
i'm not going to tell you with all due
respect how we're going to do these
things because that would put a lie risk
the lives of the people that we are
supporting and indeed uh you know other
people so so look what i would say is so
the military could come in
so we could have the military coming in
no i didn't say military i said he could
support i didn't say the military stop
jumping to lots of things i said right
it is perfectly possible on a country
that is the size of germany and france
put together with 44 million people
russia does not control the whole of
ukraine at all russia as i said this
morning has failed in its day one
objectives russia with its spec snaps
its so-called elite hasn't even been
able to take an airport that it took
yesterday russia has lost significant
amounts of armor and people the
ukrainians are fighting and they are
fighting brave it is perfectly possible
for countries around europe and the
world in fact as i do agree with you it
is their moral duty to help the ukraine
it is perfectly possible to continue to
support ukraine as we speak as you are
standing in kiev to make sure that we
give them all the aid whether it is
non-lethal aid or where possible it is
defensive lethal aid to help them defend
themselves that is possible ukraine has
a lot of fight in it you've seen that
over the night
president putin is not getting it the
way he wishes it to do and he's
currently got forces that far outnumber
ukraine but it is possible but i'm
afraid i'm not going to go on national
television and describe how we will help
ukraine because to do that you know in a
war footing scenario is to put people at
risk
right right okay
this is an unprovoked and completely
unjustifiable attack on a democratic
nation does that in your view amount to
a war crime
well it certainly amounts to a breach of
international law
in anyone's definition
and what happens on the ground is the
responsibility of the russian federation
we summoned the defense attache to the
ministry of defence yesterday i made
sure he was reminded of his obligations
under the geneva convention the track
record of russians in places like
chechnya is not good but nevertheless
those commanders whether they are senior
or junior will be held responsible and
in this day and age the good news is we
know who they are we can find out who
they are should they commit war crimes
and we will pursue them no matter what
happens in ukraine the west will pursue
them the united kingdom will pursue them
and president putin who has done this he
has to fail whether he fails militarily
or whether he fails
for the rest of his reign so to speak in
ukraine he has to fail he has to fail
because he is fighting our values and he
is fighting all the human rights that we
stand for and i don't know whether he'll
fail in ukraine we will do everything we
can to make sure he does but if he
doesn't he needs to fail after that
if if if you are going to track these
people down and you're going to hold
them to account does that mean
we will see president putin in a war
crimes court is that what you would like
to see and do you think that will ever
happen
if president putin commits a war crime
then just as i do if i were to commit a
war crime i should expect to be held to
account but you know what we're saying
at the moment isn't this already a war
crime
well i i'm not i'm afraid the the
international lawyer i couldn't tell you
the difference between breaking
international law insofar as directing
your forces to invade another country
versus a war crime eg things like
genocide and indeed uh you know torture
and and uh etc so i i wouldn't want to
speculate the difference is what i would
say is he's clearly broken international
law he's occupying or trying to occupy a
sovereign country who made one mistake
in his eyes his mistak their mistake in
his eyes was not to choose the kremlin
as a way for their future and that's all
they have done
and as we see on our telly president
putin's response to that is ultimate
force destruction lots of civilian areas
bombed and we must all never never
forget that
okay and just finally are you more
convinced now than ever that putin has
gone full tonto as you put it that he's
irrational lost his mind
i certainly think what he is doing is
deeply irrational i certainly think he
is
gone full tonto if that's what you know
what i said the other day and talking to
some soldiers you know no one else in
their right mind would do what we are
seeing on our telescreens today uh you
know no one else would impose their will
on another sovereign country uh with all
sorts of concocted conspiracies and very
bizarre readings of history unless
somehow they were acting deeply
irrationally
but that doesn't that's how comfort to
people of kiev i spoke to my defense
counterpart only a few minutes ago
and we spoke to them last night myself
in the foreign secretary our prime
minister is going to speak to president
zelinski and we will keep on going
supporting the people of ukraine